okay to review last class we discussed
uh three PR prehistorical sites right
including goe Jericho and K Hoak and the
argument I made to you um last class
which is the general scholarly
consensus is that um what drove what
compelled the transition to agriculture
was was the religious beliefs of the
people at that time okay so it was
Humanity's religious impulse that uh
drove our transition into agriculture
what I will show you today okay my
argument to you today is that this
religious impulse this need for religion
this need to understand why we are here
today and what we must be doing and
where we're going it's all always been
there okay in fact religion is what
makes us fundamentally human and to
prove this case I'm going to talk about
Ice Age cave paintings so I ask you to
look at um these cave paintings that we
found all around the world okay that go
back 30,000 40,000 years and uh as you
can see from um those pictures they're
beautiful right um and they're extremely
creative uh
artistic and um so I want to look at
three questions about the K paintings
today first of all how were they painted
they didn't have the technology we have
today so how do they paint these um cave
paintings second question is why did
they do this because when you're in a
cave it's very dark it's very cold and
it's very hard to breathe but they spend
days in there
pinning them so why do they do that okay
that's a second question the third
question is the hardest question is um
what do these cave pennings represent or
what do they
mean so um the first Cal yet the first
thing I want you to be aware of is that
there's absolutely no agreement on any
of these questions cave paintings is
something that um we have a lot of
around the world but there's very little
evidence as to what they are what they
represent and how they were painted so
there are a lot of guesses okay and the
case that I will present to you today is
my own personal interpretation based on
my research and my understanding of the
evidence but please be aware that um
there are many different interpretations
and the evidence is extremely unclear
about many of these things okay okay so
um let's start the first thing you need
to understand is that
um for most of human history it's been
very cold okay so the Ice Age only ended
about 12,000 years ago and we've seen a
general warming of the planet which is
which has allowed us to adopt
agriculture but before then we're
basically living on a very cold planet
now the history of humanity is this
300,000 years
ago um we came into being
in
Africa but because the world was became
very cold about 100,00 years ago um that
meant a scarcity of
resources and that Force us to seek food
and resources elsewhere and so that drw
of our mov movement into Europe which
then drove our movement into Asia and
then across the bearing stra remember
because this all ice right into North
America and into South America and then
from Asia we went down to Australia okay
so basically
colonized um the planet but there were
that many of us there was only about 1
million of us all around the
world 20,000 years ago and the other
thing to remember is that in this
process there were actually other human
beings in other places so the neodol
were here ne ne the the nans were here
and we interbred with them until we
became the dominant human species okay
okay so does that make sense all right
so that's the
background now let's look at some cave
paintings because uh this is in the
shoval cave and we and this started
about 30,000 years ago go so these C
paintings were a continuous process
where different people at different
times went to the caves and painted
different pictures they might have added
more things to the pictures as well okay
but as you can see this is clearly
representing animals right bis re re
rurus the other thing that's interesting
about these paintings is
that there's really no Focus okay you
see uh Lions you see horses you see
rhinos okay it's almost like nature is
one interconnected
picture
Okay um these are
lions
okay um this is Leo cave about 20,000
years ago and the most and a very famous
artist Pabla Picasso actually was
invited into one of these caves and he
said that wow we learned nothing in
10,000 years meaning that they were just
as good back then as they are today
artistically speaking humans have not
improved at all
okay um so these are
horses
okay this is alar Spain which goes back
to 34,000
BCE and uh you can see that they're not
looking for a realistic depiction of
animals okay they're trying to imagine
the natural world in their own way okay
so now the question then is
okay how did they paint these
pictures so first of all they mainly use
red and black okay red came from ochre
which is a type of clay and black comes
from charal okay so that's the coloring
they
used um inside a cave it's very dark so
they had to use lighting okay so what
they did was they got some animal animal
fat and put fire on it okay so they
could see some of the
um um caves but not all of
them okay
and then um so now the question is why
did they paint these pictures and the L
clue is this the L clue is where we
found these paintings and we found these
paintings in a very special place in the
cave we found these paintings in the
cave the section of the cave where the
Acoustics was the best the sound was the
best so what this means is is we're
fairly
convinced that these paintings were part
of a ritual which included music because
we found musical instruments as well
flutes okay so in other words we think
that these paintings are like go
goe which is like maybe now and then
these Hunter gathers would come into
this cave for a religious Festival where
there's music
dancing okay and there are
watching
these paintings together So these
paintings are part of a religious
Festival in other words these paintings
are not about art it's really about
religion it's expressing the religious
beliefs of the people at that time okay
so does this make sense guys all right
yes okay so I'm going to answer the
question what are the beliefs right now
okay all right so again no one knows
what their beliefs are because they they
wrote nothing down okay they are
preliterate um we can't go back in time
and talk to them okay so we have to use
our
imagination so let's imagine that we go
back in time to this time it's very
cold and our memories have been wiped
out meaning like we've lost the
knowledge of today we've lost science
we've lost what we learned in Biology
class okay so my first question is we're
in this world and what are things that
amaze us or make us Wonder or make us in
awe what are things that capture our
imagin
okay meaning like we see these things
we're like oh my God God must exist
because there's no way I can explain
what happened what what are these things
that we would see and we would be
surprised by be Marvel at basically
being an all off what are things about
our life that amazes us what what's the
first thing that we that we can think of
what's the first
thing you're in this world right you
should imagination what's one thing
that's like oh okay there must be a God
or there must be some Supernatural
powers that govern our world what's the
first thing that comes to
mind how about child
birth child birth
right does that make sense you guys
because I'm a father I have three kids
and I can tell you when I first saw my
child being born I was amazed because
you have this life come out of nothing
right okay and if you don't if you never
biology you can't explain what happened
so that's the first thing that amazes
about amazes us about being human
childbirth right what's the second thing
that would Amaze you you if you were
back here
yeah uh child growing up okay so child
growing up yes what
else how about
yeah okay how about the Stars right it's
it's late at night and remember there's
no
pollution so you see out into the
darkness and it's All Stars glowing
right that's pretty
amazing so what do you think these stars
are you're St into outer space right and
you see these Stars glowing brightly in
the sky what are
they what's your own explanation
really excuse
me okay possibly okay possibly
souls or other worlds okay planets
worlds in other words the first thing
that you recognize is that our world is
just one of many world out there does
that make
sense all right what what else amazes
you
about the
world excuse
me okay recovery from disease okay so
healing
right how how do you explain healing
then what thoughts save
you God oh the God save you okay all
right yeah okay so there are some
Supernatural
Powers but another way to explain
healing okay is that you have a body and
you have a soul right and the soul could
be one of the Stars so what's causing
disease in this world is the soul the
body are in conflict and so healing is
about bring the soul and the body
aligned together okay and we think this
because look at Chinese medicine right
it's the same idea right where the soul
and the body are in Conflict right and
you want to align the two in order to
heal okay so what so other things that
were surprised to is nature right the
animals the trees the vastness of
nature okay now these are things that
surprise us and they force us to ask the
question why so now let's try to
construct a theory of how to connect all
these things okay all right so we know
that the Stars there's
other powers out there right there has
to be gods or the soul of really uh
great people or other planets or other
worlds
okay how does child birth happen
then how does child birth
happen what is the womb it comes from
the womb right what's a womb then
a portal a door
right
so what the womb is is a portal that the
soul comes from another world into our
world does that make
sense then how do
people return to the other
world if the womb is a portal that
allows soul to come into our world how
do these Souls return to their world
again but but what do they do in
depth how do we so people die and
then burial thank you you understand so
this this is symmetry
right the soul comes into our world from
the mother's womb from darkness and and
then for us to return the soul back into
the original World we bury this person
in darkness that carries that person
back to the original World okay does
that make sense okay so this is probably
the simplest explanation for how life
and death works
okay all right
so these there are these portals okay
and what in nature most resem resembles
a
womb what in nature most resembles a
womb a mother's
womb like a cave right do you understand
a
cave so we can think that okay we humans
come from a mother's womb which is a
cave right a tunnel but
animals also come from womb which is the
cave okay so the cave is a portal into
another
world so why are we in the cave
celebrating
animals why are we doing
that why are we in a
cave
celebrating animals what what are we
really doing
we respect what we respect the soul and
what else are we doing because and why
are we respecting the
soul yeah we kill them right so we kill
them and now what are we trying to
do let them forgive us but what else are
are we really trying to do once we eat
them what what what must we do now
Excuse
me yes bring them back right do you
understand so when we kill them we think
they go back they go back into the
spirit world right so now we have to
summon them
back from the spirit world into our
world okay does that make sense so in
other
words what this religion what this
belief is really saying is that we are
all
interconnected and for every action that
we make we have to something else to
compensate for Action okay so if we kill
an animal for to eat the meat then we
need to ask forgiveness and then bring
this animal back into the spirit world
to maintain balance and Harmony in
nature does that make sense guys okay so
why is it in this world
there's balance in
harmony why do we think there's balance
in
harmony because what gives life to
everything what's the force that gives
life to
everything the mother goddess right
Mother Nature okay and so if we think
that there's one force the mother gods
that gives life to everything that means
that for us Trees Animals us are all
equal we're all the children of modern
nature we all have souls okay and so
what gives us permission to kill other
animals how why are we allowed to kill
other other animals the other animals
are our brothers and sisters right so
what gives us permission to kill the
other animals why why are we allowed to
do so
okay because mother nature mother
goddess has a plan okay each thing on
this planet has a function the function
is to maintain balance and Harmony if we
do not kill the other animals we will
die okay but also if you don't kill the
other animals they'll be there'll be too
many of them you understand so in other
words the world is a cycle it's a circle
and each person each animal has a part
to play in this as long as we play our
part then the world will be harmonious
and balanced and perfect okay does that
make
sense okay does that make sense guys
okay so um we have actually a word for
this religion and this word
is um animism okay animism
and what adamism is it's a very it's
probably the first religion okay it's a
belief that each living thing whether
it's a tree a mosquito a person or
anything that's living has a
soul okay and we're all
interconnected because we all have
souls and so we must maintain balance
and Harmony and so um many of the pred
religions okay if you go
to um talk to Native people in North
America and South America and Australia
they all have this belief but also there
are many religions such as Buddhism
which also has this belief okay and we
believe that this is the first religion
okay so let's go over
some um evidence that this is in fact
what they
believed Okay so
um a recent discovery that we made is
that trees talk to each other you guys
you guys know this so what happens is
that trees there are maybe thousands of
trees in a forest and their Roots con
are connected through mushrooms through
fungi and this allows us allows them to
share information so for example what we
know is that if one tree in one part of
the forest lacks nutrients like water
okay the other trees will send nutrients
to that tree does that make sense okay
so it's it's almost like the forest is
one big brain or one big living organism
and they're all trying to communicate
with with each other another thing that
we've discovered is that if there are
pths or insects that attack one tree
okay this tree will automatically
communicate to the other trees and these
trees will start to prepare for the P or
the attack Okay the third thing uh which
is the most interesting is
that trees will recognize their own
children so if the children these
children trees need nutrients the mother
trees will send the nutrients to the
children right away okay does that make
sense
so this is something that we've recently
discovered but if you think about it if
you're um living back then you can sense
the um you you can see sense almost how
trees communicate because you're always
in touch with nature okay does that make
sense all
right this is um cave
painting and you can see
that
these animals okay gazel they're going
somewhere and there are two beings here
okay we believe that these two beings
represent the mother goddess because as
we discussed last class the mother
goddess comes in the form of a bird
right the bird flies around the sky the
sky is the mother goddess okay so it's
almost like the mother goddess is
channeling or hurting the animals from
the spirit world back into our own
world what you also notice is that these
um Birds almost like humans okay and so
we what we think is that the shaman
dress up like birds in order to channel
the energy of the mother goddess to
control the animals okay okay and
there's actually a lot of evidence for
this so this is
clearly um an animal but this is Al also
a person who's an animal who who's a
human being right because of the figure
so these are human beings Shaman who
dress up like animals in order to better
communicate with animals but also to
better communicate with the spirit world
okay okay and this is actually a more
clear picture of Shaman trying to access
the spirit world
okay um are we clear so
far so from this religion we can guess
that the people back then were extremely
compassionate they believe that every
thing has a soul and every life is
precious okay and one evidence for this
is this
this is a skeleton what's interesting
about the skeleton is that it's a dwarf
okay so there are some humans back then
who are born with diseases or handicaps
or physical deformities this person is a
dwarf now this is interesting
because dwarfs aren't able to contribute
that much to your community right so as
a hunter gatherer you need to hunt
together to access meat to get meat to
feed everyone if you're a dwarf you're
not really doing that much so in theory
uh
because it's such a harsh
life being a hunter gatherer you would
think that they would discard the Dwarf
kill the dwarf or maybe leave the dwarf
behind
Okay
but from DNA analysis is what we know is
this this skeleton okay this person had
the same amount of food the same quality
of food as everyone else meaning that
even though this person was not
contributing to the
community
everyone worked hard to make sure this
person was treated well and was fed as
well as everyone else
and at the end of this person's life he
was um granted a elaborate burial okay
and we know this from the archaeological
research yeah yeah okay okay does does
that make sense
guys all right so let me ask you this
question let's make the assumption that
he was in fact contributing to the
community how could he contribute to the
community
how they clearly thought he was special
but what made him
special if you're a dwarf you can't hunt
what can you
do
me okay
um okay but what else can you do besides
food
why would they why would they think he
was a special person what could he do
that others couldn't
do
yeah thank you
okay so maybe the religion back then is
that everyone is special everyone's the
same right so if you're different it
means it doesn't mean you're less
special it means you're more special it
means that the mon goddess has given you
a special power and maybe this power is
to communicate with the spirit world
okay so maybe the C paintings as you say
were done by people like this who were
in a constant state of
meditation with the spirit world and
that's what
inspired him to create the cave
paintings okay because clearly if you
look at the cave paintings they were
done by a special
mind and if you are a dwarf you clearly
see the world in a different
way and being a dwarf it makes the more
sense to be a shamon not only because
people think you're special but because
you can invest time into meditation into
religious practice that enables you to
communicate with a spirit world okay
does that make sense
okay and not only
that um but what what we found is that
there are many burials like this okay so
this is a passage from the dawn of
everything which is a fantastic book
okay by David Grabber and David wro
they're both
anthropologists and this is a fantastic
book okay but this is a passage from
the um book so number two is the dwarf
he goes back 10,000 years okay and um it
was a pretty elaborate burial and as
this paragraph says we know he ate
exactly the same food as everyone else
okay he was not discriminated against in
any way and the last passage here is
neither is ratal an isolated case okay
we have many examples of this when
archaeologists under take balance of
apprais of hund gather burials from the
pic okay meaning Ice Age they find
high frequencies of health related
disabilities okay so the people who are
buried T to be the ones who are disabled
they have some form of
disease which makes us think that maybe
they're shamans okay they were pi to be
Shaman because hund Gods fought you're
different therefore you must be special
therefore the monag goddess favors you
okay and high levels of care until the
time of death sometimes their funerals
were remarkably lavish which meant that
they were prioritized by the community
they were highly valued by the people
around them okay the best explanation is
well they were shamans they were people
who could access the spirit world and
communicate with it okay doesn't make
sense guys all right any any more qu any
questions before I move on
all
right now what another another amazing
thing that we found about ice ice H cave
paintings is
that they have symbols okay so so we saw
pictures but um a Canadian
Anthropologist named Genevie vanon p uh
Pinger she went all around the world and
she documented symbols
in these ice HK paintings and she found
recurring symbols for example um the
hand okay there's the hand is everywhere
uh the spiral the
quadrangle the circle okay the
asteris let me ask you this
question why would paintings have
symbols why would drawings have symbols
why can't you just draw the
thing why do you need to have
symbols okay so you're right okay so we
think that this is a written language
okay it's one of the first written
languages which meant that back then
they actually had the ability to read
and write okay so maybe this is a common
language what are what are some other
possibilities why would you want to use
symbols in a
painting excuse
me to keep the con mysterious okay
that's interesting okay to keep the con
mysterious and so what so where do these
symbols come
from to keep the conent mysterious right
you have these symbols and they secret
signs where where are the secret signs
from I know but but but where do they
believe they got the signs
from okay do you understand okay so
another theory okay again we don't know
okay no one knows but like let's look at
different theories another theory is
that that this is the language of the
Gods right as you say to keep the C
mysterious to give it Divine or holy or
sacred
meaning okay does that make
sense okay what are some other
possibilities
yes exactly okay yeah so this can also
be a Shand okay we call this Shand but
also like there's some you can't draw
for example love or energy or repetition
or balance Harmony cycle right these
things you can't draw so you have to
represent them using symbols okay so
there are many different
possibilities which means this okay
let's just summarize what the
possibilities are what are the symbols
in art okay the first is that maybe
you're trying to visualize an idea okay
you can't draw energy or life force or
cycle repetition so you just have to use
a symbol to represent it okay which
means what which means that each picture
is a mythology it's a story okay do you
understand the pictures aren't trying to
show you a picture they're trying to
tell you a story about the world world
that's why symbols are important because
in in the story there are ideas that you
cannot visually Express okay does that
make sense okay that's the first thing
second thing is that you're trying to
visualize the language of the spirit
world okay so this goes back to making
the C mysterious okay why do we think
this the answer is this okay we think
that when they drew the way to access a
spirit world is to use drugs okay what
we call
psychedelics so in other words there are
certain plants that if you drink okay it
makes you see
things and the things they see are in
fact the symbols the geometric signs so
in other words they went to the spirit
world or they think they went into
spirit world and then they're just
trying to express the language of the
spirit world okay does that make sense
all right so this is a complicated idea
okay but I want to introduce this idea
to you like how we perceive or how we
understand reality so for most of human
history we thought that oh reality was
just reality and we are trying just
trying to see reality okay reality is
something that you must
see and then Along came a philosopher
and he's a very famous philosopher I
want you I want you to remember the name
but his name is
Emmanuel
Kant okay and he is considered the
greatest philosopher who ever lived
Emanuel Khan German and his idea is this
his idea is that reality is not
something that we experience or we see
reality is something that we imagine
that we create with our mind the example
he uses is time and
space okay the idea of time like one two
three four it does not exist in nature
it's not doesn't exist okay it's
something that we our minds made up so
our reality is something that we imagine
every day okay does that make
sense now what's really interesting is
that Emanuel K was writing maybe over 20
years ago okay and today we have a new
science called
Neuroscience okay Neuroscience is the
study of the brain and what's really
amazing okay and we will discuss this in
future classes is that Neuroscience has
confirm Iman meaning like we now know
that the
brain imagines reality okay it projects
reality does that make sense so what
drugs do is they change the structure of
your brain so that you you see a
different
reality okay does that make sense guys
so that's what drugs do and so when they
see a different reality maybe they're
seeing symbols okay so that's a second
thing about symbols in art the last
thing is um these symbols are mysterious
right and M mystery makes things sacred
and divine right so back to child
birth child birth is something that back
then they couldn't understand therefore
they have to believe that child birth is
sacred and div Vine and therefore women
are sacred in Divine because only women
are allow are able to give birth men are
allowed to give birth okay so back then
we believed that for most of human
history either we were egalitarian
meaning like men and women were equal or
wom had more power than men only in
recent history do men have more power
okay and how this happened I'll explain
to you next week okay but just remember
like back then there was no separation
of sexes if anything women were
considered Superior to men remember like
the God is a mother goddess a
female and therefore
women are more special than men and they
know this is because women give birth
not men okay and child birth is
mysterious does that make sense okay so
we understand symbols and art as doing
these three things now we have a more
comprehensive or complete understanding
of why they did Art okay the first
reason is what they're trying to do is
trying they're trying to visualize their
mythology okay they're trying to take
this idea they understanding
in of how the world works the religion
and they're trying to visualize it okay
so art is basically religion there's no
difference second thing is
that they're trying to
show to themselves how reality works
okay they're trying to show that the
under underlying reality is a soul or
God okay does that make sense the last
thing which is the most important is
they're trying to create a common memory
and
Imagination a language mythology that
they all share together okay and this is
what we call
Society does that make sense so in other
words okay the argument I'm trying to
make you trying to make you the argument
I'm trying to make to you today is one
religion has always been there since the
dawn of humanity
okay that's the first second thing is
that
religion allows us to communicate with
each other to be together in
society so the third thing the third
thing is religion is what allows us to
be fundamentally human without religion
we could not be human we could not think
we can not communicate we could not
imagine does it make sense guys
okay any questions about this okay now
let's look
at a
quote okay what is religion okay and
this is from Emil Duram okay and I want
you remember the name Eman Emil Duram
okay he's he's just as famous as Emanuel
K Emil Duram is considered the founder
of
Sociology okay so when you go to
university and you study sociology guess
what you'll mainly be
studying uh em doram okay so this is
what he says about religion religion is
above all okay first and foremost
religion is this a system of ideas by
which men imagine the Society of which
they are members okay it's to create
society and the Obscure yet intimate
relations they have with it okay
religion is a way for them to understand
the
world all right does that make sense
guys all
right so let's look at what he
says again in more
detail okay so the great service that
religions have rendered to thought is to
have constructed a first representation
of the relations of kinship between
things might be okay so what this is
saying is that religion allows us to
construct an understanding of the
world okay so basically the first
religion was this right and this is just
a theory of the world this is
important because from this Theory we
are able to construct more
theories all right given the conditions
in which it was tried that Enterprise
could obviously
lead only to makeshift results okay
meaning that okay well listen religion
it's all about guessing it's all
about hypothesizing okay so you know a
lot of these ideas AR going to work out
that doesn't
matter but then are the results of any
such Enterprise ever definitive and must
it not be taken up up again and again
okay so our desire to know our
curiosity forces us to constantly
reimagine our
religion furthermore it was less
important to succeed than to DARE the
fact that we try is what was
important what has what was essential
was not to be to was not to let the mind
be dominated by what appears to the
senses okay but instead to teach the
mind to dominate it and to join together
what the senses put a shunder so as
human beings we're not trying to
see the world or trying to imagine the
world okay that's what makes us human
okay going back to uel Kant our ability
to imagine reality is what makes us
fundamentally
human as soon as men became aware that
internal connections exist between
things science and philosophy became
possible so from religion we develop
develop philosophy and Science in fact
you can say that science today is our
religion
okay there's really no difference it's
just an understanding of the
world based on our imagination and some
evidence religion made a way for them it
is because religion is a social thing
that it could play this role to make men
take control of sense Impressions and
replace them with a new way of Imaging
the real a new kind of thought had to be
created Collective thought okay so
religion is our Collective Consciousness
it's what every it's what allows Society
to come into
being if Collective thought alone had
the power to achieve this here is the
reason creating a whole world of ideals
through which the world of sense
realities seem transfigured would
require a hyper exitation of
intellectual forces that is only
possible in and through Society okay
it's only because we are together are we
allow are we inspired to come up with
religion so religion is fundamental to
being to Being
Human without religion there could be no
Society without Society there could also
be no
religion okay you understand so the
implication of all this is like as a
human first of all you are not alone if
you're alone you're not be human you're
a human because you live in society
you're with other people and because
you're with other people you must have a
collective Consciousness or an idea you
share together and we call this being
religion okay does that make
sense is this clear to you
guys all right any
questions anything you are not clear
about do you see how all this connects
together okay the cave paintings is what
started cave paintings is expression of
a religion then when the ice age ended
we had a chance to settle down we
created communities to celebrate our
religion that's what gave R to
agriculture okay and the religion that
we use is probably probably something
like this okay the world is
interconnected there's a mother goddess
that gives light to
everything
okay any
questions anything you are you you you
you're unclear
about
yeah okay so that's a good question okay
so the question is monotheism okay
so the mo the three major religions of
today uh Christianity
Islam
um and uh Judaism okay they're all
monotheistic meaning they believe in one
God um so this is actually a very recent
Innovation okay
so um back then they wouldn't have a
concept of power our
hierarchy you understand they wouldn't
think that the mother mother godess is
the greatest god of all they could only
think like the stars right there's no
hierarchy in the Stars they're over the
place okay so maybe the mother goddess
gives birth to our world but maybe
there's another God that gives birth to
another world okay so they wouldn't
think in terms of hierarchy we think in
terms of hierarch today because of
monotheism but back then they wouldn't
think so does that make
sense
yeah so maybe maybe today you can think
of a pyramid okay there's people at the
top but back then they would think think
like it's a
river okay we're all part of the river
it's a cycle it just goes in
circles and there's no differentiation
or there's no power power hierarchy
things go wrong when there's conflict
inside this River okay when people don't
do things they're supposed to be
doing okay so and what and these things
are
what what are things that defy the
mother goddess or go against the the the
mother
goddess how about incests right how
about killing animals without making the
proper
sacrifices right so you just kill the
animals but you don't go in the cave to
uh pray for them for for for their
return okay so in other words in this
world religion is basically
ritual and this is something that we'll
study next class how religion is just
ritual okay just a just habits and
practices and
actions any more questions that that's a
great question by the way but monotheism
is something that we will look at very
closely in future classes and it's very
important because it's a basis for our
society okay
any any other
questions
yeah
yes well you can't live in a cave
though right you can't live in a
cave you can only go there now and then
there there's no oxygen in the cave it's
too dark it's too cold you can't live
there
right so you're right in that okay if a
cave were
livable they um could build farms around
that cave
okay
so okay that's actually a great question
okay besides caves what are some other
portals in the
world what are some other portals in the
world that have like spiritual energy
besides
caves in in nature if you were back then
you would think that this place is
special because it both connects our
world and spirit world and these places
would
be mountain tops right mountain
tops guess what goe was on a Mountaintop
okay where where else would there be
portals
Rivers
okay
Rivers does that make sense these are
places that people would think are
portals into the out into another world
and therefore they are
special and we find that when they
settled down and build agriculture they
did so on mountaintops and they did so
around Rivers okay does that make sense
but not caves because you could actually
live in caves
okay does that answer your
question you can't live in a cave
there's no food and it's cold and it's
wet oh they oh great question okay yeah
so they liveed outside in
tents no no you can't live in a cave
there's no
Oxygen
okay any any more
questions okay so your question actually
makes me think of a point I I want to
end the class with okay so today we
think that we are either economic
animals
economic animals or uh biological
animals okay so the person who
introduced us like who introduced to us
the idea that we are economic animals is
called marks okay and his argument is
that we are driven by our need to have
money okay that's what what we believe
today right you're in school because you
want to go good grades so you can go get
go go get into a good University and
then you can go get a good job okay now
there are other people who believe that
we are biological animals and these are
people people are called evolutionary
biologists they are inspired by Charles
Darwin so the idea here is that we are
motivated by our desire to spread our
genes okay so if I'm a man I want to
sleep with as many women as possible
because if I sleep with as many women as
possible I spread my genes right but if
you're a woman you want to find a man
who will be loyal to you because the
cost of childbearing child wearing is
very high okay does that make sense so
and we'll be discussing both these
theories um more throughout the semester
okay the argument I want I I want to
make to you today is that no we are
first and foremost a
religious animal we have the fundamental
need to understand why we are here we
have a fundamental need to connect with
everyone okay to connect with other
people but that does not mean that we
are
not economic and B bologal animals okay
they all play together you understand so
what we'll see later in the semester is
that you might have a religion but this
religion is not meeting your economic
and bial needs then you have to either
abandon the religion or change the
religion okay but we also know that the
economic need is not enough you also
need religion so there is an interplay
between economics biology and
religion okay and that's what drives
human history something that we we will
learn more about uh next week okay sorry
next
week okay so um yeah any more
questions okay